the patriots never put their foot
anywhere but on the gas right to the
floor when they can and that's what we
saw the bills do i was actually a little
surprised last night when they called
the dogs off in the fourth quarter and
put matt barkley in instead of josh
allen because we've seen time and again
where belichick will keep tom brady on
the field until there's three minutes
left in the game or three seconds left
in the game but the bills thumping the
patriots handing them their worst defeat
since 31-0 week one of the 2003 season
the lawyer malloy game when the bills
beat the patriots patriot win the super
bowl that year so it worked out well but
ugly
but at the same time beautiful
if you're a fan of josh allen stefan
diggs or good offensive football because
the bills had plenty of it last night oh
well i mean first off you're right we've
never seen the patriots like that that
was it was kind of crazy to see you know
even bill belichick i feel like even the
look of some of the assistants on the
sidelines it was a little like i can't
believe we're in this situation i felt
like you saw that on their face and we
we talked about like i i don't know the
terminator was dead a few weeks ago but
last night i don't know what that was i
guess that was the officially like
lowering into the lava there like it's
official we need to recreate and build a
new machine because it is over there uh
but man mike
whoo baby my boy blue
my boy blue looking good i mean on fire
the bill's on fire sean mcdermott you
know we played here to open the show no
sean your guys are good it's okay to say
it you are good you're really good in
fact you are one of the best teams in
football and we continue to see them on
this arc of going up to where
they have it all mike i mean they really
do you have a quarterback who can make
plays as good as anybody in the game
they got a running game now to where yes
it's not awesome but it's good to where
you can't disrespect it and just say oh
we're just gonna play coverage on stefan
diggs and the rest of these wide
receivers all game long and we're seeing
the defense really turn around too i'm
really impressed with the bills the
transformation they've made the maturity
they've shown this year to kind of
you know like we talked about last week
they went through a phase early in the
year where i think they thought they
were good they got smacked in the mouth
a little bit and then we're like whoa
wait we need to reassess we're not as
good as we thought and they really took
it as a positive and built on that and i
got to give mcdermott a lot of credit
for it
and the running game gets a boost when
you've got a quarterback who has the
ability and willingness to pull the ball
down and ronnie had four carries for 35
yards last night including a 22-yard
scamper that initially looked like it
was going to be called back due to a
penalty but the penalty was on the
patriots i remember last year going into
the playoffs one of the things we
thought they would do is unleash him as
a runner i don't know that they need to
this year because you're doing so well
as a passer but if there is a greater
willingness
to take off with the ball
then
that's only going to help the offense
and i feel like last night's game the
fourth straight
nationally televised game involving the
bills and they're 4-0 in those games two
monday night a sunday night and a
saturday afternoon where it was the only
thing happening stand-alone broadcast on
nfl network i think the culmination of
this 25 of the season run for the bills
had warnings
for what teams are going to have to deal
with in the postseason they ran a fake
punt who the hell runs a fake punt when
you've already got your division title
one and you're playing a team that
you're obviously better than and will
beat over the course of 60 minutes
something to think about for the kansas
city chiefs or anyone else they may
encounter in the post season josh allen
running the ball 22 yards something to
be ready for something to be afraid of
something to plan for pick your poison
when you're dealing with the bills and
they're good enough that this is one of
the next level things that you do when
you're that good you start laying the
foundation for what's to come in the
playoffs and you know you can do that
and still win by 29 points no you're
right you're right well it's just giving
your team another little bit of an
advantage you know whether it's the team
preparing for you or hey that moment
where you just go we need to do
something to get some energy going we're
a little flat right now but you know
they have trick plays we've seen them do
a number of those over the last few
weeks i i think it's all of it i just
think they're a team that is totally in
the groove on both sides of the football
and josh allen last night i don't know
what else you can you know really say
about the guy i mean some of the plays
and throws we saw last night at a josh
allen are just outstanding they're
outstanding forget like hey in the
pocket the lasers he throw forget that
he should have another touchdown pass on
his resume from last night and they
dropped two on the same drive i mean but
it's the plays off schedule to where
bill belichick must have been sitting
there going wait we covered them for six
and seven seconds and nobody was open
and then he still made a guy miss and
moved out of the pocket and got a 20
yard gain
the guy is throwing for 70 percent
and i would argue his degree of
difficulty on throws is higher than
anybody in the sport that's what's
impressive and he's just got he's found
the fine line and i thought greasy did a
good job of explaining this last night
of
he's always been able to hit the
bullseye he's always been able to do
that hey josh throw it hit that
bull's-eye bam i got it no problem it's
the decision-making along with it that
has impr improved the accuracy you know
he used to get out of the pocket and
make a throw and just be like hey i see
a receiver he's in between four people
and i'm gonna try to jam it in there no
now he's found the fine line to go okay
that's a little tight but i can get that
in there and then oh whoa that's way too
tight i'm not going to jam it in there
i'm going to throw it away and he's
really become a true complete
quarterback and that's what makes them
really dangerous to me uh in the
playoffs right now
last night he completed 75 of his passes
27 for 36 320 yards four touchdown
passes a rating of 138.7
let's hear from josh allen talking about
his motivation last night even though
they already had the division title
wrapped
it's an up
well coached team and
uh
you know i i know this game
you know
if they didn't want to admit it it meant
a lot to uh both sides you know it's a
lot of pride on the line for us you know
we're trying to be number two seed
um you know we'll put ourselves in a
position where you know we can go get
that in week 17 and we know that we got
a hungry miami team coming to us and um
you know they're they're playing to get
into the playoffs and uh we got to be
ready for everything that they can throw
at us they did say that uh you said that
you weren't buying into the josh allen
mvp craze a couple times is that a fair
interpretation of what you said to them
i've said multiple times that josh
allen's a good football player and he's
played well and he's having a good year
oh mr happy well of course there was
nothing to be happy about at least the
demeanor matches the result for a change
the guy has acted like someone who's
been losing 38 to nine every year for
the last 20 years and seriously finally
he has a reason to be a little bit
grumpy although the full season has been
a bad one for the patriots back to allen
something that i thought of when
listening to you and considering last
night there was a moment where he was
moving to his right he grew to his left
it was on target and as i think it was
greasy greasy and riddick sounds so much
alike sometimes i can't tell who's who
but i think it was greasy
who said that they always tell you don't
throw across your body well you do it
when you can you do that stuff when you
know you can do it and chris when
patrick mahomes was taking the nfl by
storm in 2018 josh allen's rookie year i
remember it dawning on me at some point
he's going to inspire a generation of
kids to try to do the things he can and
there will be a certain percentage of
kids who realize they can right do the
things that patrick mahomes can
one thing i hadn't considered until
90 seconds ago uh-huh i think you're
right also may have inspired he also may
have inspired josh allen yeah to try to
do some things that maybe josh allen
hadn't previously tried to do because
when you've got the arm and you've got
the accuracy and you've got the mobility
you throw it all in a bowl like egg and
milk and flour and you start stirring it
around and you realize you can bake
yourself a patrick mahomes cake
that may be and that would be i think
irony it probably would be irony
although i never quite know whether or
not that word is the proper one to use
if it's allen versus mahomes
and the bills give mahomes and the
chiefs everything they can handle with
alan inspired by my homes playing like
my homes beating mahomes mike i i think
it's a very valid observation i do
you know
i think you're right mahomes broke
barriers in the nfl he has i mean again
you know not that it always gets
publicized but hey his no-look throws
we see there's no throws in football
almost every week now because of patrick
mahomes what he did there then also i
think all the scrambling and throwing
across the field in those plays you know
i think a lot of teams and if you have a
quarterback like josh allende you're
saying look at it and go you know this
guy i got pulling the trigger he he's no
dummy he's kind of smart he doesn't like
he's not gonna i trust him now and man
when he does throw it across the field
we make plays we get 15 20 yard gains do
things like that to where i do feel like
offensive coordinators head coaches the
quarterbacks just being more ready to go
than ever before because they've thrown
the ball 50 000 times before they've
gotten the nfl like we've talked about
whether it's college football the seven
on sevens everything football being a
year-round sport from when you're 10
years old now to where
it's not as crazy anymore to do that
type of stuff and josh allen certainly
has the talent and mike i mean
i i you know the allen vs mahomes thing
just uh that that little part of it uh i
i would think those like i think allen
thinks about mahomes i do of course i
mean everybody thinks about my homes
he's the man
but i would bet you mahomes
and his brain looks at allen as one of
the guys where he's like uh that guy's a
little bit
too damn good and threatening my king of
the hill status right here and i don't
like it and i think it's it's one of the
few guys in football that i think could
threaten mahomes for his greatness and
his ability to make magic so much
and and you just have to wonder and
again you don't you don't see it very
frequently because you need the natural
ability that alan has but you have to
wonder how many guys on the fly this
isn't just kids
developing these powers when they're
eight nine no no you're not god guys
inspired by
mahomes and maybe now inspired by alan
to try to do more things with that
combination of accuracy arm strength and
mobility also helps to have stefan digs
and look this trade that brought digs to
buffalo from minnesota you can call it a
win-win although i think right now the
vikings would say if they could
undo the trade they would say we're fine
because they're happy with justin
jefferson who's on the way up the bill's
got digs when he was already at or close
to the top had the ability to be one of
the best receivers in the nfl just
needed to have the ball thrown his way
more frequently by someone who had the
ability to get him the ball more
frequently and whether it was
disenchantment with the vikings
run-based offense or disenchantment with
kirk cousins
he recently admitted that it was
not in his best interest to be in an
offense that was going to run the ball
so much although i think cousins played
a role in it but diggs has been
incredible look at this first in targets
with 158 first in catches with 120 and
1459 receiving yards unbelievable
performance this year from dickson it
took him a while to get going last night
but man once he got going chris that was
one of his best games ever and and this
is just what special teams do
they seize those late
season big moments where everyone's
watching
and they show everyone this isn't a
fluke this is real and we're coming yes
yeah i i mean
coming and i mean to the point where we
know the chiefs are king
but i just sit there and look at the
bills and go
man
that i think a round two can be very
interesting i don't think this bill's
team's the same bills team that the
chiefs beat you know 26 to what was that
17 earlier this year on that makeup you
know rainy day up in buffalo
i think it'll be a different a whole
different type of football game all
together and you talk about
like digs it is special it just shows
you really
again as another great example of a guy
getting in a place where his
he's on a team that knows how to utilize
his skill set completely it fits the
right way you know so he goes there and
they have an offense that has just a
wide variety of different routes and
different things to do and we've talked
about it a lot mike's diggs has no
weakness he's a precision route runner
he's quick you know he's strong he's got
straightaway speed and i think that's
the thing that's jumped out to me i i
don't know you tell me you've been mr
minnesota vikings the last few years and
all that but like
i
i just i think i took for granted how
explosive he is and how like we saw last
night he can catch a slant and break a
tackle why somebody's hitting him that's
the aspect that i don't know if i knew
he had until this year and it's it's
been very special
well i think part of it too is the
talent and the skill set doesn't
flourish until it's used on a regular
basis and maybe you learn for yourself
there are things you can do that you
haven't had the chance to do in a game
setting and it leads to more confidence
and it leads to that just that you just
had attitude that he has and he's got it
and it's great and we've always loved
stefan diggs and it's great to see him
flourish the way that he is and it's
great to see what the bills are doing
and i had to improve him as a person
mike i mean he seems like a different
guy just from what you hear in the
telecast and everything about it like
he's just he's so comfortable and happy
that now he's the leader of the football
team to where he was just like you know
an awesome player who kind of just i
think stood in the background with the
minnesota vikings and so that speaks to
the culture there too
common affliction for the receiver
position guys want the ball and when
they don't get the ball they react a
certain way and we saw enough of that
from diggs over the years when he wasn't
getting the ball and he wasn't feeling
like it was going their way he reacted a
certain way and there were flashes this
year and i think it was in that chiefs
game walking back to the line of
scrimmage late in the game when they
were trying to move the ball down the
field when you're winning and when
you're getting the ball it's all fine
it
can suddenly be not fine
when it goes the other way but for digs
in the bills this year it's been great
and i had a vision i had an image i have
a a flash forward to bill's chiefs in
the afc championship game
barring an upset of either team because
that's now especially for the bills and
i don't think the bills are going to
succumb to it because it's been so long
yeah since they've done anything in the
postseason they're not going to take any
opponent for granted i believe
but
the chiefs have what 15 000 fans at
their games you know what's gonna happen
there's gonna be bills fans that are
gonna make chiefs fans offers they can't
refuse for that ticket whatever it takes
however much money you want they're
gonna make a pilgrimage to kansas city
and there will be bills fans in that
venue
and we still don't know that the bills
are going to have fans for their home
playoff games they've submitted a plan
that would entail like 6 700 i think is
the number that i saw but th this
this could be an afc championship unlike
any other could be the first time this
year that the bills are in that kind of
a big moment where they look up in the
stands and they see
a lot of bills fans there and that may
give them the kick i don't want to fast
forward through the postseason because i
think it's gonna be a great postseason
but my god if conference championship
sunday includes bills at chiefs chris
that may be as good as the super bowl
well it it would be unbelievable it's
the two of the hottest quarterbacks in
the game really exciting offenses that
are high flying can do a lot of you know
fun stuff as far as explosive plays all
of that
defenses like neither one is like the
steel curtain but both are really good
defenses who show
you know that they can rise to the
challenge in big moments and they create
plays and do things like that and i mean
fan bases it doesn't get better than any
of the those two right there really mike
i thought that was going to happen to
the chiefs last year at the super bowl
what you're talking about what the bills
might do to them i'd be surprised if the
chiefs let the bills come in and throw
money around like that the bills fans
last year i thought oh here comes you
know
san francisco all you know the 49ers all
the big shot you know west coast money
people the silicon valley all that crowd
everything i thought oh they're gonna
end up buying the chiefs out and of
course we watched the game on tv and
everything like that and it was 80 to 20
chiefs so i i would think the chiefs
protect their excuse me i'm drooling on
myself uh their kingdom and don't sell
out too easily to the bill's mafia
we're both drooling as we think about
this possibility of bill's chiefs in the
playoffs and you know and it is
at the same time
it's disappointing that the patriots
aren't the patriots anymore but it is
kind of nice to have some some fresh
blood at the top of the nfl and uh let's
let's spin it around to the patriots for
a little bit cool because i think this
is a major rebuild this isn't something
where oh we've got 51 million in cap
space this off season we can go out and
address all of our problems i think
their problems run far deeper than any
one position especially on offense
here's bill belichick talking about his
team's offensive struggles on monday
night
we didn't have much production we had
just the combination of things
and protection drop balls
this lack of good execution
and we just didn't
just didn't execute the passing game
well and they they played they played
well defensively um
with their pressure and they covered
well so they did a better job than we
did
you know i still think the dam would
have broken at some point last night for
the bills but on that first drive as the
patriots are moving down the field and
they they pull out the trick play they
try to out buffalo buffalo and damir
bird just flat out drops a ball to hit
him up high near the shoulder pads you
never do that pops out
i that that that was it the the balloon
was pumping up early and that was the
pin prick it still took the bills a
while to really get it going but
how different the game becomes
if you turn that play into seven points
and strike like that and give your
offense a lift and a boost and i think
especially at cam newton he needs
confidence to build confidence to build
more confidence and once it gets rolling
he can be unstoppable that that was
their opportunity to get it rolling
chris and it failed yeah agreed i mean
you know we we know we've seen it all
year they're a team that can't play from
behind
you know they want to try to get the
lead control the football run the
football run out the clock you know
the way the game perfectly could have
set up for new england is yeah score a
touchdown there
you know
then then okay maybe buffalo gets a
field goal they get the ball another
long drive maybe it's a touchdown or a
field goal and they hope that they get
you flustered on offense a little bit
like no no whoa whoa when now we're down
and then the belichicks feel like they
got you because they start to play games
in the secondary and do things like that
that's what they want to happen that's
really the only way they can win a
football game right now with what they
have there but yeah
i mean major rebuild there's no doubt i
mean we talked about this you know
last year when brady was there you know
i think there was even talks of it the
year they beat the rams in the super
bowl like how much longer will this team
last all of that it's just all come to
its finality you know between the
coveted guys being gone and then
those issues of course some of the draft
picks but when you look at their
football team there's only two spots on
the team where you go it doesn't need a
rebuild and that's like the offensive
line which is really awesome
and the secondary and that still has
some questions too because you got jc
jackson who's gonna be a free agent
gilmore a lot of people are not sure
what's gonna happen there so
yeah the bill i mean uh bill and and the
patriots they got their work cut out for
them and they're going to have to make
some major moves
in free agency and of course have a good
draft to just set their team up to try
to figure something out to get back on
the the successful you know path again
and the narrative has come up from time
to time over the years that bill
belichick the head coach is so good he
can overcome the periodic failures of
bill belichick the general manager even
though he doesn't hold the title he's de
facto in charge he's got final say he
runs the show nick casario sets the
table like scott pioli did before him
but
at some point they do have to do better
at acquiring talent in the draft
especially at the receiver position
where they have failed over and over and
over again to to properly scout and
choose and develop young receivers it's
it's abysmal don't draft them anymore
like that's what i would say don't you
just find proven commodities that you've
already seen in the nfl they seem to be
better that way than they do with the oh
we're going to evaluate the young guy no
just go with a guy that you've seen in
person on the field in the nfl he knows
he's good and sign them up and make it
work that way i mean you're right i
don't trust them with draft in that
position
and and it's not something that you can
quickly fix although if the salary cap
drops to 175 as some think it still will
i think that's a bit of a ruse that's
going on between the union and the
league and their back and forth and
that's a broader negotiation that's
going to happen i think it's going to be
higher than 175 because the teams don't
want to have to cut a bunch of good
players but if that happens that
benefits the patriots because if a bunch
of good players get cut some of them
will be receivers the patriots have the
cap space they could go out and get some
veterans yeah the quarterback position
though is going to be the first thing
they need to address
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports